I am going to start with the sound this
is the sound of Wikipedia it is showing
you the live edits to Wikipedia as they
are happening right now across
30 or so languages
what you see is basically the article
names that are being edited by the
editors and you see the additions and
removal of content or reversion of
content you see edits by editors who are
logged in in green and those which are
by anonymous editors in white and you
see the bata activity in purple so I'm
showing this usually at the beginning of
the presentations to say that Wikipedia
is a living system it is there and it's
changing as we speak and as we are
trying to figure out what to do to help
it improve I'm also sharing it to say
that there's an enormous amount of good
faith and volunteer work that is
happening behind the project even the
screen that you're seeing is the result
of it at 3:00 to developers and one
designer who works at their volunteer
time to make this happen so with this
I'll start talking about my presentation
I'm just going to reduce the volume
sadly and even maybe lose it to talk
with you about research as the service
of free knowledge so as Mike I said my
name is Leila Zia I am the head of
research at Wikimedia Foundation and I
have the opportunity to work with six
amazing research scientists and design
researchers to do this actually today we
have two of the research scientists in
the room Martin and Miriam are in the
room they are visiting from Berlin and
London
we have Wikimedia Foundation has the All
Hands meeting next week so more of our
employees are coming from all over the
world to San Francisco to meet during
the next week
before I go to the details of the
presentation I should say that what I
will say is not the views of my employer
necessarily and definitely not
necessarily the views of Wikimedia
community and volunteers so please
consider that in what you hear so I'm
going to start talking about a project
that started in 2001 with
humble goal of becoming an online
encyclopedia that anyone can edit and
access for free
the humble project has turned to the
largest encyclopedia that humankind has
ever built has resulted in almost 50
million articles that today exists in
Wikipedia in more than 280 languages
with 10 million monthly edits and you
saw some of them just now as they were
coming in and 15 billion monthly page
views on top of all it's a project that
is run and governed by volunteers
so roughly there are 200,000 register
than 300,000 unregistered volunteers who
contribute to the project and these are
the people who day in and day out make
Wikipedia happen Wikipedia over the past
years has turned into a major entry
point for learning for us we go to
Wikipedia for a variety of reasons with
it actually we did a research to figure
out why people come to Wikipedia and
what we learned is that there are people
have different motivations when they
come to Wikipedia we go there if we are
intrigued by a topic that we want to
learn more about or we are bored and or
randomly want to explore a topic we have
a conversation with someone and we want
to follow up on a fact we read something
or we see something in movies and we
want to follow up and see what's
happening on Wikipedia we have a worker
school-related project there's a current
event there is a disease there's an
outbreak there is an attack there are
personal decisions that we want to make
about what medical content what medical
treatment we should we should use and
for all of these reasons from across the
world we go to Wikipedia and we expect
to see answers and we expect to see
reliable answers but Wikipedia is not
only used by humans Wikipedia is used by
machines to build algorithms and by
platforms to develop other products on
top of the high quality data that is
being gathered by hundreds of thousands
of volunteers in Wikipedia
this doesn't need really major
introduction to use or pacify this one
relatively quickly but a lot of the
technologies that we use today while we
think that we're not going to Wikipedia
they're actually empowered by the data
that exists in Wikipedia thanks to the
high quality data technologies like Siri
Apple watch the knowledge bases that you
see the knowledge panel that you see in
Google a lot of them are at least
receiving some content from Wikipedia
and then some of them are completely
relying on the Wikipedia or data that
exists in wiki data this kind of usage
of Wikipedia is kind of advancing
further and further you see even
platforms such as using Facebook or
YouTube using the Wikipedia as a source
to direct traffic of viewers of their
videos to try to understand if to help
them understand about and learn more
about controversial topics so a humble
project which was supposed to be an
online encyclopedia that anyone can
freely edit and access for free is now
becoming more and more responsible from
the platform specialist perspective to
handle some of these bigger challenges
that the world faces and by the way
Wikipedia editors have pretty strong
perspective on this front Wikipedia is
based on verifiability are not truth and
we don't recommend linking to be TPD
afore truth searching so all of this to
say that Wikipedia has become a
centerpiece of our world whether we go
to it directly or not we use it in our
everyday everyday life in a variety of
ways and to some extent it has become
sort of the epistemic backbone of the
web and as a result it's really
important to understand what is this
project and how we can help to improve
it or empower the editors to improve it
I will briefly talk about the role of
Wikimedia Foundation where as a kind of
an elephant in the room and I'll pass
this one slide quickly Wikimedia
Foundation is the foundation that
operates Wikipedia it is a nonprofit
organization we are around 380 employees
mostly removed meaning
the headquarter is in San Francisco but
we primarily don't work from the San
Francisco office our job is not to
interfere with the content on the
projects that that's the job of the
volunteer editors and we also do not
enforce policies for the most parts on
the projects it is the responsibility
and the governance model of Wikipedia
for editors to decide what policies need
to go under projects and how they are
going to implement them if they need
help they will ask for help what we do
primarily is basically supporting this
community and this surface thing you've
got the content across the globe
so we basically maintain the data
centers we have servers we have a legal
team that supports the community we have
a communications team and also a
research team and product teams that
build certain types of products and with
that I'm gonna talk briefly about the
context we are operating right now in
yeah we have a global multilingual
project which is run by volunteers which
has a really radical objective and this
radical objective creates a lot of work
for these volunteers the objective is to
empower everyone in the planet to be
able to share in the sum of all
knowledge and as much as we like to
think otherwise empowering people to
share in the sum of all knowledge can be
considered very radical they say the
project has created created a
significant reliance by algorithms and
platforms for coming to the project and
developing the next levels of technology
there is the need to reach more people
and more audiences and also there's a
need on behalf of the project to include
more people so primarily wikipedia has
been has been built by the contributions
of the people again primarily in global
north and western part of north america
and western part of europe and there's a
big desire to change this dynamic to
diversify the editor pool and be able to
open up as a community and bring more
people into wikipedia and help them
contribute to the project
and the last thing I want you to
remember that there's a non-profit
behind the project right beyond the
volunteers who do the amazing work at
the end of the day there's a non-profit
project that is responsible for servers
on kind of the basics of the operations
and this is the context in which we talk
about the research and Wikipedia I say
this component the context I at the
beginning to say that we are a small
team of researchers my team is a team of
six plus one researchers who focus on
Wikipedia so you can imagine at the
scale of Wikipedia with the kind of
problems that you're already guessing
that we're going to talk about there's
going to be a lot of demand for this
small team so part of our work is to
make sure we empower researchers like
yourself
to be able to become volunteer
researchers for Wikipedia or at least
empower other people for example
developers to by releasing datasets and
doing putting api's out and making it
the results of our work publicly
available kind of find the knots that
can empower by unknotting them we can
empower more people to contribute to the
project primarily in the research team
we focus on three areas of research you
can there's a link to the white papers
that we have for each of these and you
can learn more about them if you're
interested we focus on addressing
knowledge gaps which is about
identifying what are the knowledge gaps
on Wikimedia projects and finding ways
to address them I'll go through a few
examples of the work that we do in this
space the other one is around improving
knowledge integrity which is about the
reliability and quality of the content
on Wikipedia and ways for assuring the
quality and also improving the quality
that exists on the project and the last
one is about the building the foundation
doing the foundational work that is
needed for example releasing datasets or
building relationships with the
researchers in academia and industry
across the globe or other ways to
basically expand the network of
researchers and developers that exists
around Wikipedia and through that
basically build a strong foundation for
the project to survive from to continue
surviving on the development and
research perspective
I'm not going to talk about the last
component which is building the
foundations today so much I'll briefly
mention a few ways you can engage
otherwise I'm going to focus on the
first two and in the first two there's a
lot I can talk about so I thought maybe
I can drill down on one or two examples
a little bit more and make sure that I
leave enough time for you all to ask
questions because usually most of the
exciting things happen in Q&A not in the
presentation it's not in my presentation
so I'm going to talk about addressing
knowledge gaps first this the workshop
I'm going to talk about is in
collaboration with Jesus in Germany EPFL
in Lausanne and Stanford and I'm gonna
talk with you first about what we
envision as the primary direction for
the knowledge gap space so we want to
identify the Wikimedia knowledge gaps
this means we want to understand what
content we're missing but not only
content who are we missing in terms of
readership and contributor shape and we
also want to understand what is the
relationship between these different
entities what is the effect of missing
certain types of contributors what
happens if we don't have enough women on
Wikipedia does it have impact on
readership or not and how does it
reflect itself if it has the other thing
that we want to be able to do is to
measure and prioritize missing content
this actually turns out not to be an
easy task what is missing from the
projects is sometimes easy to measure
and in many times it's not because it
requires speaking to the bodies of
knowledge that exists outside of
Wikipedia and having ways for
prioritizing this missing content we
want to be able to address these
knowledge gaps and actually the first
project that I'm going to talk with you
about is gonna kind of touch on the
first three bullet points and the last
thing which is kind of on a more
ambitious front we want to be able to
build a knowledge gap or and knowledge
equity index so we want to be able to
have an index that can help decision
maker at the let's say higher leadership
level across the movement to be able to
look at this index and say these are the
areas that we should invest in or we
should pay more attention to more
directional it's not meant for
day-to-day operation purposes so I'm
going to start talking about the first
project this is I need to explain this
map maybe a little bit before digging
deeper this is the map of the world each
point that you see on the map if it's
blue it means that there is one
Wikipedia article about that coordinate
on Wikipedia right and if it's yellow it
means there are two or three and if it's
white it means there are at least ten
articles about that coordinate on
Wikipedia this is not the representation
of all knowledge that can exist on
Wikipedia because a lot of knowledge is
not cannot be associated with
coordinates the reason that I'm showing
you this to you is that it gives you a
sense of how much we are missing content
on Wikipedia so this is English
Wikipedia if English is the only
language you speak this is how much you
can learn about the world in terms of
things that coordinate about now let's
switch to Russian Wikipedia with 250
million native speakers this is how much
you can learn Spanish Wikipedia is not
much better and I want to bring your
attention to the fact that obviously
closer to Spain you see a lot of
activities and courting creation of
articles happening but you would expect
a lot of this to happen in South America
as well and that's an area that we are
missing a lot of content again this
narrow specific type of content
Portuguese is not better and Arabic is
pitch-dark
right I mean you have some areas that
are that we know more about but pretty
much it's it's it's a dark map this
doesn't become better or much better
when you overlay the maps right when you
overlay the maps meaning if you speak
all the languages that exist in
Wikipedia close to 300 you still have a
lot of missing points it's closer to
English than a complete map of the world
so this being of this think back in 2015
2014 2015 and 2016 about this
pick up how can we grow how can we help
editors grow Wikipedia faster we're
definitely growing it there's a lot of
contributions you saw it as they were
coming but it seems it's not fast enough
part of the work that you can do is on
basically working on efforts to bring
you more editors on the projects but the
other effort that we focused on was can
we build the system that can
automatically detect what what content
is missing in Wikipedia prioritize it
and recommended to editors and that's
what we basically built we try to find
the articles that are missing from
Wikipedia and the way we did it is that
we chose the easier path which is
comparing Wikipedia languages with each
other
figuring out in if an article exists in
one language but is missing in another
language so we didn't search outside of
the Wikipedia space and we found let's
say at the time an English Wikipedia we
had three million articles and in French
we had one to 1.2 million articles so we
so we found 1.8 million articles that
existed in English could potentially
exist in French Wikipedia but we're
missing at the time in the in the
project but then of course not all those
1.8 billion or high priority for French
Wikipedia to have those articles some of
them actually the French Wikipedia
community may decide they don't want to
have articles about it because the
notions of notability can differ across
projects so what we did is that we built
a ranking model to rank how important
the article is for that project and the
ranking model would basically predict
how many page views the article would
receive if the article were to be
written in French Wikipedia let's say
well there were a lot of interesting
discussions around whether pageviews is
a good metric there or not but that's
what we use and then we did a relatively
simple matching problem so we build
topical models for editors based on
their edit history we build topical
models for articles that are missing in
a language given that they exist in
another language and then we solve the
matching problem within an experiment
where we invited 12,000 editors who
spoke both French and English or what
country
to both French and English Wikipedia to
participate in the experiment we took
the top 300,000 articles on the ranked
list of articles that we saw we divided
them into three groups a help a group
and one group that was assigned at
random to the to 6,000 of the editors
and the top group that in which we did
the personalization which is tuning
basically doing the matching as opposed
to just assigning errors randomly to the
articles and what we saw that it was
that if you do personalized
recommendations you can increase article
creation rate by a factor of almost 3.2
without compromising on quality this was
a big result back then it's always nice
to get this kind of results in in
experiments but experiments always have
their drawbacks and caveats so what we
did is that we set up a research tool
which is still up and you can go in and
play with but more importantly we made a
production API out of this model
actually be simplified model further
because for production I using this
across 300 languages basically pers that
you need to consider we needed to do a
lot more work so we simplified the
ranking step and the matching step and
we surfaced API publicly there are some
developer tools that are using this API
today one point that I want to say is
that the content translation tool within
Wikimedia Foundation picked up the API
and decided to use it and back then the
content translation tool was kind of in
very limited use so we had around like
50 articles created per week and after
the adoption we were seeing within the
period of two to three months we were
seeing 1500 Arctic has been created
every week and then more recently when
we looked at the statistics what we
could see is that roughly more than 20%
of the new translations are coming
through the suggestions that are coming
from the API we didn't do any further
ABT's this is mostly just looking at
what what the split of translations are
right now so this is one example to say
that sometimes the kind of work that we
do relatively smoothly ends up in
production and when it ends up in
production
it can actually end up empowering the
editors that are contributing to the
projects what we realized after this
project was that it was not enough to do
recommendations to editors for creating
articles what can happen is that you can
recommend for an article to be created
and in practice that article remains a
stub on the project stubs are very short
articles which are deemed not to be
encyclopedic basically from the editor
space perspective so if you if the
editors takes a job very lightly they
can take your recommendation put a title
page in the language write every one
liner done and then you have achieved
creation of one article in fact what we
saw is that 37% of english wikipedia
articles are stops and these are
articles that are considered non
encyclopedic by the definition of
editors and they need to be expanded to
remain on on the encyclopedia for the
longer term and this english wikipedia
is already one of the better cases of
wikipedia in terms of development of
content on the project so what we
decided to do is go deeper than the
article level so instead of recommending
what articles to create how about we
take the stuff that already exists on
Wikipedia and recommend what sections to
be added to the already existing
articles on Wikipedia this is how the
tool will eventually maybe someday we'll
look we did one line of work with
Tiziano Picardie and Metallica Thurston
and Bob West which was around using
focusing on a Wikipedia language in in a
specific language and then using the
information in that language from the
category network of Wikipedia extracting
extracting information about the
different sections that that can exist
in the in that category in the Articles
that belong to that category and
basically doing simple frequency
counting and what we could see is that
we could achieve a precision at ten of
around eighty percent which was
reasonable the challenge we faced then
was that if you are in a smaller
language where the category network is
not developed or well developed what
should happen then one idea would be to
take the category network from English
Wikipedia
then send it to that language and this
line of work receives a lot of
resistance so there is a there is good
arguments to be made that the diversity
of expression of content on Wikipedia
across languages is something that we
want to preserve so taking your
structure of the category network from a
large language let's say such as English
Wikipedia and putting that in smaller
languages is not desirable from the
cultural and cultural representation
perspective so we are working actually
on a different approach at the moment to
address this problem for the
medium-sized and smaller sized languages
I don't have results to show at the
moment until we push the work further
out I am going to switch to readership
which is another thing I wanted to talk
with you about today in the context of
addressing knowledge gaps we started
doing a bunch of work in this space
starting around 2016 and back then what
we realize is that we know we're really
very little about the readers of
Wikipedia because the editor data is
primarily publicly available researchers
had accessed this to this data basically
from the very early days of Wikipedia so
you see a lot more research and
development and understanding around
what editors do on the projects while
the readership aspect is pretty much
unknown so we started the first line of
work around why we read Wikipedia where
we attempted to build a taxonomy of
Wikipedia use cases and then from there
we ran surveys on English Wikipedia and
we asked people basically to help us get
a sense of what is the representation of
readership across these use cases maybe
I should move forward yeah all explained
is here we built the taxonomy and then
in 2017 2018 what we did is that we took
the taxonomy that we developed in 2016
and 17 and we ran these surveys in 14
languages in Wikipedia basically asking
people about their motivations for
coming to makea pedia you saw in the
early slides like the
motivation questions the depth of
knowledge that they're seeking in their
visit and whether they're familiar or
unfamiliar with the topic that the
reading what we see through what we saw
through the surveys that we ran in a
nutshell one of the interesting results
that we saw is that the country that the
reader is in has impact on the use cases
that wikipedia has for that reader so
generally what we saw is that if you
come to Wikipedia from a country that
has low Human Development Index which
means lower socioeconomic status and
also lower access to health and
education you tend to read Wikipedia
articles more in depth you also tend to
read more scientific and less leisure
oriented topics on while you are on
Wikipedia and this is in contrast to if
you're coming from countries which have
very high Human Development Index
so in these countries you tend to have
users that more do fact-checking or
coming for very quick reads of Wikipedia
and they also read Wikipedia more or
they read more of leisure oriented
topics on Wikipedia when I say leisure
oriented I mean sports movies that type
of topic so what we decided to do in
2019 was to expand the study and the
main question that we had when we
started this was on the country
component so we saw that there are
differences between people when they're
in different countries but it was not
clear to us what are these differences
are at the individual level or not right
so if I'm an Iranian sitting here in the
Bay Area is my behavior basically
captured by the fact that I am in the US
or is it I am carrying some something
some cultural or background with me that
has impact on the way I use Wikipedia so
with this last round of surveys we are
trying to get to the answer to that
question so we added some demographic
questions to the surveys and we also try
to sample more heavily from Africa to be
able to understand that
user population better here's how the
survey is run basically if you're
selected to participate in the survey
you receive a pop-up that says take a
short survey or help us improve
Wikipedia on mobile or desktop and then
if you say yes then you will be taken to
the survey to answer some questions we
collect the responses to the survey and
then we join those with a bunch of other
information that we have one of them is
that we know which article you were on
when you responded to the survey so we
had we extract the information about the
article from Wikipedia and then we also
have access to web request logs and that
with a law that allows us to have
information about session length and the
Geo Coordination basically because we
have the request information we have the
time of the day you could you connect
that to Wikipedia what country you were
connecting from as much as your IP can
speak to that item to that country and
aggregated we use all of this
information to be able to make sense of
the data that we received from the
surveys we ran the 2019 surveys for one
week and I will come to the one week
right now to say that eventually we
repeated it for one month as well to see
if the result changes if we do it and
the short answer is no so we ran it in
13 languages three motivation questions
and then five demographic questions
around age gender education the locale
of the person and their native language
and we connected collected around 65,000
responses from the readers of Wikipedia
I want to share with you some of the
results although it may look like just
some statistics to share to share with
you maybe some of the challenges that
Wikipedia faces and we face as Beyonder
we try to understand Wikipedia so the
first question we had was our current
Wikipedia readers representative of the
population that the word has or that we
think we Camellia should have and and
this obviously has a lot of implications
that the representation of readers it
has impact on the way we do product
initiatives or do investments in
different regions
and the short answer is no and maybe
it's no all the time but it was for us
it was no in a surprising way and I'll
move forward to show you those so we
asked the question about what is your
age on the x-axis you can see the
different languages that we have for
French and English we have two sets of
responses from the world and from Africa
specifically and what you immediately
observe is that the majority of the
respondents in almost every language
we're less than 25 years old and German
and Norwegians are exceptions in in this
case we see some spikes in or drops in
Spanish and Hebrew and we think that
maybe the school session school was in
session during that time one thing I
want to point out here is that this
immediately raises some questions for us
so we see that a lot of population is
actually really young but as researchers
we have limitations on who we can ask
questions of so generally in many
countries users under age 18 or
considered minors so what we do in these
surveys is that the first question you
receive is your age and if you say that
your age is under 18 you basically are
sent to the last page and if you are
over 18 then you participate in the rest
of the survey but here one challenge we
have is moving forward knowing that a
lot of our population that the current
reader population is young there's a
question of what do these people want
what do they want to take out of
Wikipedia and we haven't figured out a
good way to answer that question yet the
other question is what is your gender
and maybe I'll take a couple of guesses
before showing this what do you think
the gender distribution would be and
just to keep it kind of very simple here
we asked for we basically have four
options for responses men women prefer
not to say or neither of the two and I'm
going to show you only the man and woman
split its readership right it's
fifty/fifty okay let's do it
and it's not fifty-fifty and it's pretty
yeah we want to understand boy so the
majority of the respondents in almost
every language seem to be men and one
thing I didn't actually mentioned
earlier that I should have is that we do
as much as we can we take we do the
biasing steps on these surveys so as I
showed to you we collect a lot of
features and through these features we
do the way that propensity score
matching and we do the biasing so what
you're seeing here is actually as much
as we could that the biased results from
the survey yeah so this is what's
happening on Wikipedia in terms of
readership in these projects maybe one
good news that I'm not showing here is
that we also looked at this data across
age groups and what we are seeing is
that in younger age groups this split is
very close to 50/50 and as people age
basically the split grows this can mean
many things it can mean that oh we fix
the problem and the newer generations
are not going to have this problem or it
can mean that as women age and they have
other social responsibilities in life
we're going to see this issue in in this
currently younger generation later on as
well how many years of full-time
education the people have had
so generally 13 to 16 years of education
is what's happening in the in the
readers in the readership of Wikipedia
this is we have the country information
from other datasets that are publicly
available that can help us understand
that this is in general on average two
to four more years more than the average
education of the people in these
countries and this has implications
right as we're thinking about including
more people having content that is more
accessible to more people thinking about
the fact that you need 16 years of
education before being able to
communicate with the content or inter I
or learn from it
obviously I'm not suggesting that that's
the only reason I mean there may be many
reasons that people don't end up on
Wikipedia but this is something good for
us to keep in mind and with this I'm
gonna maybe skip a couple of slide just
to talk with you about this part which
is about whether readership gaps and
content gaps on Wikipedia are related
this is early results and we are seeing
some signals that these may be related
more specifically what we are seeing is
that in many of the languages so what
you see here on the left-hand side it
basically on Arabic Wikipedia you see
the first leftmost left bar is men
reading about men then you have we women
reading about men and then women reading
about women and women reading reading
about women sorry reading man reading
about women and women reading about
women so what you see here is some early
signals that in many languages men read
relatively more frequently about men and
women read more frequently about women
and this is just focused on the
biographies of men and women on
Wikipedia what you also see that is that
in almost all languages younger readers
read about people who are younger and
older readers read about people who are
older this early signals suggest that
there's maybe more to it we don't have
any definitive claims to make here right
now but we were going to be looking into
this space more closely to try to
understand the interactions between
content and readership yeah that's
something that needs to be fixed I know
that there has been studies finding that
there are fewer female biography it has
not changed
in that sense it suggests that since
you're almost like doing better than
baseline but I mean it's still it's not
a great situation right yeah this needs
to be looked into further and
normalizing definitely for the number of
biographies okay I'll move forward to
talk with you maybe for a few minutes
I'm not going to go through a lot of
details about this utter actually maybe
I should talk about the open questions
that we have in the in the knowledge gap
space before I go to the next one
in terms of open questions in content
there's one question we have which is
how to find knowledge that is not
already on the projects across languages
content types and in a scalable way what
is our way for finding what is missing
on Wikipedia the other one is that as we
are thinking about looking at external
knowledge sources and figuring out
what's missing it's important for us to
think about the notability component
because at the moment editors are making
that first decision of is this notable
I'm gonna write an encyclopedic content
about it and in the first research that
I showed you what we do is that become
per basically language editions with
each other so at least at the first
entry of the knowledge to one Wikipedia
language an editor has made a choice
that this is notable if we go to the
outside world there is the question of
well there's a lot out there what is
considered from the encyclopedic view
notable to exist in an encyclopedia in
terms of readership there is a question
about how can we address the imbalance
of readership that we see specifically I
would call it the case of gender
imbalance that we are seeing this is
something that we need to get to the
bottom of there are more imbalances
definitely that we see there but I would
say that's kind of the more acute one
and it's like kind of the more visible
one that we think we should be able to
address how do how do people learn on
Wikipedia what do they actually do when
they come under projects what is their
trajectories and what does learning even
mean
how do we measure it on on Wikipedia
what is the role of visual knowledge we
talk a lot about text in this first part
and there's a question that people have
different different learning moves and
what it takes to bring more images to
Wikipedia and or other types of media
that can help people with different
needs
learn more smoothie while they're on the
projects and our images are currently
being used what are the navigational
patterns of readers on Wikipedia in
terms of contributor ship I would say we
have a few questions here one is that
how do we help diversify the editor pool
is something that I don't talk about
here it's an area of immense interest to
different stakeholders within the
community and on the more general part
what is the relationship between content
readership and contributor ship what are
the tension points what are the places
that one helps the other eye or
undermines the other and how do we
measure these knowledge gaps I want to
leave enough time for you all to ask
questions if you want to so what I'm
going to do is that I'm gonna pass
through this next part relatively
quickly give you a gist of what's
happening in the knowledge integrity
front so the challenge that we have in
this space is that we have readers that
trust the content that they read on
Wikipedia and we see this through the
qualitative studies that we do and we
also see that they don't consult with
citations as often as we hope to so in
the pages that have the references
available to them only one out of 200
page views results in a citation check
which we appreciate the trust but from
the editor perspective they always want
the reader to verify the content that
the reader reading every second
Wikipedia receives around five edits
that means a lot of edits that are
coming in and a lot of all of these
edits will need to go through a lot of
judgment cards while when you make the
edit the edit becomes immediately
available to the world it goes to a
backlog of work for patrollers to check
the edit the edit needs to be checked in
terms of neutrality or in terms of
whether it's verifiable whether you have
four
right sources whether it's about
somebody who is a living person and if
the content doesn't have sources then
it's like immediately problematic so my
edit results in more work for others and
we're doing a lot of edits which is a
good thing but then the issue is that
also editors and adversaries are really
few in numbers and there are also
language barriers while English English
Wikipedia has around a few hundred or a
thousand administrators this becomes
very challenging if you go to smaller
languages like Persian Wikipedia or
Malagasy Wikipedia and the language
becomes a barrier for the editors from
other projects or admins from other
projects to be able to come in and help
if this language needs help in terms of
maintaining the quality of content and
of course there are organized groups
governments who try to interfere with
the content right so you have a
volunteer-based very dedicated volunteer
base was push the project for almost 20
years forward and you have all these
forces that sometimes are working with
it and sometimes against it
so generally patrollers and
administrators need to take a lot of
decisions very quickly on Wikipedia
their backlog is ever-growing in many
areas especially in larger languages
like English Wikipedia and the question
is we that we have is how can we support
them with with the technology that we
can develop either within the steamer or
outside of this team to support them to
make some decisions more efficiently so
the direction that we go in this space
of knowledge integrity is primarily
focused on identifying characterizing
and addressing the threats to the
integrity of the knowledge on the
projects helping editors in for monitor
and enforce their core content policies
verifying knowledge in the absence of
secondary information which is a big
topic for us as we are trying to include
more people with more forms of knowledge
in the projects there's a question of
what if they don't have a secondary
source available to back up their their
claim and then also characterizing the
integrity of multimedia knowledge which
is something we are really
recently introducing to the team I think
it's best probably for me to stop here
and open it for questions Michael do you
think it's good or okay what do you all
prefer talk or chew any questions yeah
that's no questions then yeah say one
thing before I wrap this up as part of
the conference happening if you're doing
already work in the media space you're
interested to come present in the
workshop our next deadline for
submission is February 2017 that's the
link for it we can workshop dot-org and
credits and thank you yep I can take
questions
yes and I think this is something first
of all this is outside of the area of my
expertise so what I will tell you is
kind of based on my personal experience
and what I'm observing happening in the
other teams I think we as Wikimedia
Foundation we don't have a lot of
experience building new communities we
have maybe more experience let me
correct us building new communities or
empowering new communities in areas that
no basic seeds exist so if you are
living let's say in a country or a
region that you already have for example
open source advocates in your region
right or you already have some develop
developer skills you already have skills
around like adding context digitization
like some basic infrastructure if that
exists it's easier to start doing kind
of the initial seed of investment
basically giving some small grants
trying to bring this community together
in areas of the world where those seeds
don't exist I don't know even yeah where
would we start basically yes so it is it
is very complex and it's very different
it can be very different from language
to language so what you see on English
Wikipedia can be very different than
what you see in Hindi Wikipedia and
generally the way it works is that for
the most part once you make the edit
your edit appears on on the project and
immediately visible to the readers as
the patrollers review or if somebody
Flags
the content as being problematic or
attempts to revert it maybe two things
can happen one is that if a patroller
reviews your content and decides that
there's a problem with this they usually
notify you and then you have some time
to react and if you don't react then the
content gets reverted or in some cases
deleted it can get more complicated
there are let's say you do Wikimedia
Commons which is the media repository
for a big media project every time you
upload an image on Wikimedia Commons it
needs to go under let's say for example
a free license free free license license
model you see sometimes photographers
coming back and saying I want to delete
my image right and technically something
that you have published under the free
license cannot be deleted right so
sometimes some community conversations
will need to happen about that specific
case I would say on the Edit cases there
are also cases in which like there are a
lot of wars like going back and forth
reverting each other and at some points
admins can come in and lock the page if
the situation escalates in other
articles they can go through like
partial banning of the username if that
username is logged in banning the range
of IP if they are not logged in
basically if it gets to vandalism and
those kind of things and then there
arbitration committees and affiliation
committees and like there's basically is
like a whole world behind this that
depending on the case may kick in for
these a controversial topics where there
is a lot of back-and-forth
I didn't going on the user may come in
at any moment and only get exposed to
one side of the story is there a way
that to to inform the user that this is
a controversial topic and then you
should make me come back later to check
so in theory yes
in practice it's been hard so part of
the issue is how to figure out whether
this is controversial and you would
expect that you can go to the talk pages
of Wikipedia so every article you may
know already has a TOC page associated
with it where editors discuss basically
the things that are happening in that
specific article so in theory you should
be able to build a model that can say
which part of that talk page this
discussion is about which part of the
article and then maybe create some
summaries of this is the status or there
are too many things happening it's
already a sign that something may be
going on and surfacing that to the to
the reader one of the challenges is that
the TOC pages are not structured and
analyzing the data and doing the
matching between the two is not obvious
but it's definitely a very interesting
area to to look into the other thing I
would say is that in TOC pages not only
for the controversial topics but when
these controversies happened or happen
or when editors disagree you get amazing
outcomes out of those conversations that
don't show up in the articles themselves
but are there in the TOC pages like
things as simple as how do you define a
sandwich right and at the end you go and
read the article but there's a lot of
discussion about like how should be the
bread and what are the specific
specifications of that bread right
and there's that wealth of knowledge is
hidden currently in the talk pages and
while maybe the sandwich is not the most
interesting topic to you there are other
topics that can be more interesting and
I think definitely there needs to be
much more work for looking at that data
and linking it there's also the question
of how the bias spreads for example on
the article page and what is the
relationship between bias spreading on
the article page and what's happening on
the talk pages right and what is the
relationship has downstream on people
and on thoughts and so on sort of on how
we discuss the topics that are covered
in the PPT you can imagine that if
everyone sort of centrally coming to a
Wikipedia page understand the topic that
how that's described could influence
like public conversations around that
topic in the same way that you know a
news source can sort of set in some ways
conversation agenda do you think it
would be possible to actually track that
or do you feel that the influence is
actually pointing in the other direction
that it's happening elsewhere I mean
getting reflected in or out so there are
two things maybe I can say immediately
to your question what is that under
science in the topic of science there
has been controlled studies that show
that what happens on Wikipedia the
language in which science is described
in Wikipedia then influences the
academic language of how papers are
being written there was a controlled
study in my folks in MIT a few years
back that showed this so there's
definitely evidence that what happens on
wiki on Wikipedia has impact on the
language the way of thinking in science
or at least in specific parts of science
there is related to your question
there's another kind of body of our work
that one person in our team
Isaac Johnson has started on
understanding how to measure reuse of
content and I think and correct me if
I'm wrong I think understanding how how
to even figure out where the
conversation is happening which is
related to the reuse question is a first
step before we can get to your question
of okay now that that we know how to
find where the content is being
discussed now let's figure out what are
what are the
types of conversations and what's
happening whether it's coming back to
Wikipedia or not yes
but this is very interesting
you'll talk you mentioned that there are
organized groups that's trying to
manipulate content the pasta yeah so we
have reports from the communities that
in some of the languages there are
government involvement in the project
there has been and these are not all
fully confirmed but let's say for
example in Persian Wikipedia there are
discussions about that there's an in
Russian Wikipedia there are discussions
about that in Chinese Wikipedia
zah basically experienced some of this
some years back there are also attempts
that are not maybe directly done by the
government but are nevertheless attempts
that weaken the project potentially for
example the recent case that got
resolved eventually was that the
government of Turkey was requesting a
change of content on Wikipedia and
Wikimedia Wikipedia editors didn't agree
to the change and they said well no
these are like facts and they're
supported and as a result basically
Turkey blocked the whole of Wikipedia
for almost three years in Turkey right
so basically 80 million people lost
their access to the free knowledge right
so there are while maybe they attempted
made maybe not while they didn't change
the content directly there are
consequences for a government's appetite
for changing the content these are not
the only places and sorry you had a
second part to your question or so one
of the things that the program that I
just talked about about knowledge
integrity we would like to understand
we're doing one project with Sir John
Kumar and you Ray here on sock puppet
detection we're on sock puppets our
accounts that are operated by one person
and a lot of at least some of the
activities that we see which are
organized they create a lot of sock
puppets on Wikipedia so at least we know
we can catch maybe some of them through
those methods
and then the other one is we don't
understand actually how this information
spreads on the project so we would like
to start a line of research or two on
this front to understand what are the
mechanisms through which this
information mostly organized this
information spreading on the projects
and then what can be done basically
territory governments are now using AI
two steps to prevent censorship by AI so
there are some things I can comment on
and that is if we see us as a foundation
and this is primarily outside of my
team's work if we observe well two
things one is that the detection of it
and the detection is not very obvious
right how do you detect that you're
missing part of your population because
if they do a kind of complete block it's
relatively easy to understand you you
lose basically traffic from the country
or region or completely but detecting is
not obvious and that is something that
we have been working on on our end and
then once the detection kind of confirms
and the local sources confirmed that yes
there's something happening then that's
where usually the policy angle of legal
and policy angle of Wikimedia Foundation
kicks in right and there's a lot of
arguments to be made about access to
knowledge as a human right and that's
the angle that that team tries to push
and make cases for two different
governments any other questions
it's mothers kids I think everything
yeah so the question was whether there
are opportunities for translation or
efforts for translation from one
language to our to the other so there's
the there are editors who do translation
without any specific tools but there's
also the content translation tool that
is developed by Wikimedia Foundation
that error is used for doing
translations specific topical areas of
Wikipedia organized around translations
in certain way so for example there is
wiki project medicine that basically
there have as part of their vision to
make sure that medical content is
immediately available across many
languages and they do kind of very
organized physicians sitting and doing
kind of translation in these languages I
would say just one thing to keep in mind
as kind of the point that always comes
back when we think about translation is
what do we lose when we do the
translation right and which language we
translate from - and what is the
proficiency of the people who are doing
the translation how much of the cultural
context they keep as they do the
translation and there's definitely the
tension between sometimes they need to
bring the content to the reader as soon
as possible
for example if you have an outbreak
versus the need to preserve your culture
and the way you represent and the way
you learn and understand and that's kind
of one of the topics of conversation
usually around translations
[Applause]